at least 21 people have been killed and
dozens more wounded in Russian Artillery
strikes in and around the Ukrainian City
at her son they hit one of the few
working hypermarkets in the city
partially destroying it a railway
station petrol station and residential
buildings were also hit Tama al-samadi
reports now from Harrison
we're outside the largest shopping mall
in the heart of Curson the venue was
shelled and as a result the entire
building was damaged
you can see the impact on the ground and
there's also one of the many dead bodies
still lying around we were told he was
one of the workers
several people were killed and a dozen
injured in this attack Ukrainian
authorities say the Russians are
constantly shelling major shopping
centers and residential communities in
the city
they also reported other fatalities on
the front lines as Russia intensifies
its artillery missile and Rocket attacks
along the Eastern Bank of the nipro
river in kuson which is now under
Russia's control